él tiene muchísima influencia de las
películas italianas las bubis de cine de
arte este películas de culto pues al
final de cuentas tratamos de crear un
universo medio oscura la idea de hacer
cine en un mundo digital pero que
parezca a filmado en cinta no con mucho
color creamos escenarios obviamente
sacándole provecho a la locación
principal que es la riviera maya y bueno
filmamos abajo del agua este tenemos
pues como algunos retos que se
presentaron y que en el producto final
pues se ven ahí plasmados además sacamos
de aprovecho también a tus propios
talentos porque además lo que estuve
viendo entre las cosas que ya has hecho
está la filmación bajo el agua es una de
sus especialidades sintiendo bien sí sí
sí de hecho pues bueno soy buzo
certificado y a partir de esa
desinterés que yo tuve por el agua
empecé a filmar bajo el agua ya lleva un
tiempo haciéndolo y pues bueno es todo
todo un universo este diferente
contratamos obviamente a un equipo de
protección porque cuando nada más yo era
el único estaba buceando pues bueno en
fin fueron algunos retos técnicos que
puedan podrán verse en pantalla no ahora
cuéntame trabajar con este equipo bueno
pequeño equipo canadiense porque en
realidad está compuesto por tiempo reno
gautier y con quien más viaja reno no se
esté el viajó también con con jake que
es el productor ejecutivo de la película
el viaje también este bueno es
interesante porque la protagonista mujer
patricia ella es también franco
canadiense pero ella radicando allá en
playa del carmen durante el periodo de
la filmación
pues si había una mayoría del club
éramos mexicanos pero bueno si había una
componente franco-canadiense importante
también pues muy internacional la verdad
es que a la hora de hacer el casting
playa del carmen es un lugar que
propicia este tipo de interacción entre
culturas distintas si te pareció entrar
en el universo de reno gautier porque
tiene su propio universo hablabas de
todas las influencias que tiene del cine
de culto y el cine italiano etcétera
pero que como cómo te insertas te tú con
tu propia experiencia y con tu propio
background de director y de
cinematógrafo al universo de re no fue
fácil difícil interesante no sé pues
pues la verdad mira es el ac bueno en
sus dos primeros largometrajes
pues crea un universo de terror de cosas
pues
de situaciones que pueden parecer
comunes como como ir a una discoteca
como como ir a un parque de diversiones
no y les da esta pues como este twist de
película de terror cosa que también pasa
en punta siniestra obviamente yo traté
como trabajo de cinematógrafo pues
tratar de entender la visión de de reno
que fue directamente y yéndonos hacia
asia al cine clásico al cine de la
década de los 70s se tomaron muchas
influencias también visualmente como
como de películas como taxi driver de
escocés películas como scarface y
películas como 'el padrino' incluso
entonces tratando nosotros de recrear
esa ese pues es el look cinematográfico
de 35 milímetros de la década de los 70
es la verdad es que yo
el trabajo que había hecho como
cinematógrafo había sido un poco más más
actual y fue un reto por supuesto porque
pues obviamente es el cine de muchísimo
nivel en donde hay que cuidar como como
se exponía y cómo se exponía cómo se
traducía esta exposición a la película
de cine no entonces obviamente ahora en
la época digital pues tenemos
herramientas que nos permiten como
degradar la imagen porque la imagen
actualmente es demasiado
fidedigna demasiado es demasiado buena
entonces realmente pues eso a la hora de
querer recrear eso tenemos que degradar
la imagen yo estuve también aquí
involucrado en el proceso de lethal on
ag
trabajando en un centro de producción
sea posmoderno y pues bueno nos pasamos
prácticamente todo el tiempo degradando
la imagen para que te diera esta
sensación
de la época clásica del cine entonces
pues fue un reto claro que fue un reto
pero pero bueno interesantísimo este fue
un reto no nada más el volvernos y
trasladarnos a cómo se hacían como se
hacía el cine antes sino también el reto
de poder transmitir esa emoción y esa
magia que genera reno en sus películas
[Música]